Just over two weeks until Hannukah, three until Christmas,...
...and the latest data suggests Americans are still spending...
...with 40 year high inflation continuing to ease.
October consumer spending just out, shows the biggest gain since June,...
...even as families pay more for rent, food, and new cars.
Retailers report nearly 200 million people flock to stores...
...from Thanksgiving through Cyber Monday.
In Atlanta, Whitney and Joe Novak own Kazoo Toys...
...and say shoppers are inflation sensitive, but still buy.
We've had a good year, we're positive, I mean, we're keeping people employed.
We're not concerned.
Toys is one of those nice industries...
...where we're not going to have the huge ups and downs,...
...roller coaster of supply, really.
Kids are always going to want toys.
Inflation in October, running at six percent, slightly lower than September.
FED Chairman Jay Powell, now says the Federal Reserve...
...could soon slow the pace of its interest rate hikes aimed at taming inflation.
The time for moderating the pace of rate increases may come...
...as soon as the December meeting.
That could mean a half point rate hike in two weeks,...
...rather than another 3/4 point hike.
Meanwhile, gas prices are now averaging $3.47 a gallon,...
...down 28 cents in a month.
Third quarter GDP, even stronger than first reported.
We're kind of waiting for a recession like they were waiting for Godot.
It hasn't happened yet.
And each month that goes by, the economy proves itself to be more resilient.
Consumers keep spending.
Tomorrow, we'll get the November jobs report.
200,000 new jobs expected.
Data the Fed will use when deciding...
...whether it really can slow the pace of rate hikes in December.